merci à vous si vous nous rejoignez sur
public sénat suivre dans un instant en
direct la séance de questions cribles
thématiques consacrées aujourd'hui à la
rentrée scolaire c'est luc chatel
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
vient répondre aux questions des
sénateurs près de 16000 postes quasiment
tous de profs de professeurs vont être
supprimés à la rentrée dont près de 9000
dans les écoles publiques
ces suppressions de postes dans le
primaire entraîneront à la rentrée 1500
fermetures de classes au moment où les
et que les écoles accueilleront 4 900
élèves de plus les syndicats
d'enseignants ont appelé à une grève
unitaire le 27 septembre prochain tout
de suite donc à direction l'hémicycle où
il va être largement question de ces
suppressions de postes très bonne séance
à tous de posséder hors démographie à
aucune fermeture
si je salue l'engagement du président de
nombreux problèmes persistent pour la
rentrée 2011
que ce soit au sein des écoles primaires
des collèges ou des lycées
en effet ce ne sont pas moins de 6000
suppressions de postes qui vont avoir
lieu si je comprends la politique de
notre gouvernement qui s'est engagé sur
la réduction de l'endettement de l'état
et des déficits publics sur plusieurs
années je m'inquiète des coupes et du
manque de moyens et surtout de temps
d'adaptation auquel doivent faire face
nombre de nos écoles collèges lycées et
collectivités je prendrai pour exemple
on départements la marne pour le premier
degré le département se voir retiré 37
postes alors que le nombre d'élèves sera
en augmentation
il en va de même pour le second degré
certaines classes vont en effet
atteindre le nombre de 30 et plus
au-delà des conséquences évidentes sur
les conditions de travail
se pose également des difficultés en
termes de sécurité des locaux et
d'adaptation de la taille des classes
certaines ne seront pas assez spacieuse
ni adaptée à l'accueil d'élèves en
fauteuil roulant notamment ni équipés du
matériel informatique nécessaire aux
nouvelles exigences de l'éducation
nationale le plus souvent ce sont les
milieux ruraux qui sont le plus affectés
par ces suppressions de postes le 23
juin 2006
la charte des services publics en milieu
rural était signé elle prévoit
concernant la carte scolaire que les
autorités académiques doivent informer
les exécutifs l'auto locaux concernés
deux ans avant les projets d'ouvertures
ou de fermeture de classes du premier
degré
force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui ce
principe n'est pas appliquée tout du
moins dans mon département
pourriez vous me dire monsieur le
ministre les mesures que compte mettre
en oeuvre le gouvernement afin de
pallier à ces manquements auxquels nos
collectivités les enseignants et les
parents d'élèves ont de plus en plus de
difficultés à faire face pour vous
répondre la parole est un monsieur luc
chatel ministre de l'éducation nationale
de la jeunesse et la vie associative
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur françoise férat l'éducation
nationale ne manque pas de moyens
vous avez voté vous majorité sénatoriale
un budget en augmentation de 1,6 pour
cent cette année de plus de 60 milliards
d'euros qui est le premier budget de
l'état 22% du budget de la nation est
consacrée à l'éducation nationale et
c'est le budget le plus important jamais
voter par un parlement pour l'éducation
nationale je rappelle simplement un chip
madame le sénateur en trente ans la
dépense par élève dans notre pays a
augmenté de 80 % en euros constants ça
veut dire que les moyens sont là la
question est de savoir comment ces
moyens doivent être répartis alors oui
c'est vrai le gouvernement le président
de la république s'est engagé à ne pas
remplacer la moitié des fonctionnaires
qui partent en retraite mais madame le
sénateur je dois immédiatement vous
préciser que à la rentrée prochaine
si on prend du recul et si on regarde la
situation dans les établissements
scolaires sur une longue période il y
aura plus de professeurs et moins
d'élèves qu'il y en avait il ya vingt
ans dans le système éducatif
donc le taux d'encadrement est
aujourd'hui meilleur qui n'était il ya
20 ans deuxième élément madame le
sénateur
cette politique de non remplacement elle
nous permet de mener une politique de
revalorisation de nos enseignants que
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
socialistes vous n'avez pas été capable
de mettre en place
et nous avons augmenté nos salaires de
nos enseignants de 10% en début de
carrière
ce qui est exceptionnel dans
l'environnement économique budgétaire
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui au
niveau européen alors que certains pays
licencient leurs fonctionnaires alors
que d'autres baisse la rémunération le
non-remplacement d'un fonctionnaire pour
2 nous a permis de revaloriser de
manière significative nos enseignants et
tous nos fonctionnaires je rappelle
mesdames et messieurs que le pouvoir
d'achat des fonctionnaires a augmenté de
3,1 pour cent l'année dernière
alors madame le sénateur nous menons
cette politique avec discernement j'ai
donné des instructions claires pour que
l'on tienne compte de la carte locale
qu'il y ait des concertations qui soient
menées avec les élus qu'on travaille de
manière prospective à ce que l'offre
scolaire salamou s'adapter je suis élu
d'un département rural je connais les
problématiques de départements ruraux
afin de ne pas impacter la vie dans les
milieux ruraux
mais madame le sénateur le choix
aujourd'hui c'est une éducation
nationale de qualité l'éducation
nationale qui personnalise qui
différencie les moyens qui fait
davantage pour les élèves qui en ont le
plus besoin
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant mal à me faire avec lui et
moi merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je suis en parfait accord
avec vous ça n'est pas une question de
moyens mais pardonnez moi d'assister
parce que sur le terrain les difficultés
sont bien réels que ce soit les élus les
parents d'élèves les enseignants tous ne
témoigne très régulièrement leurs
problèmes alors un seul exemple monsieur
le ministre cette rentrée va voir
arriver quarante mille nouveaux élèves
en classe de 6ème et nous allons dans le
même temps avoir une suppression de 4800
postes de professeurs alors je ne
focalise pas sur la charte des services
ça n'est pas ce n'est pas mon propos
mais est il utopique monsieur ministre
d'imaginer une autre procédure qui
réunira l'ensemble des interlocuteurs
concernés
alors j'entends par là les maires les
associations départementales des maires
pour les écoles primaires les conseils
généraux pour les collèges les rayons
pour les glisser et enfin les
enseignants les parents d'élèves autour
de l'inspecteur d'académie
il me semble que cette concertation
permettra sûrement entre personnalités
responsables de prendre en compte ce que
vous dit fort justement l'année
c'est rigueur budgétaire mais sans que
cela nuise à la qualité de
l'enseignement que nous devons à nos
enfants
moi je me pose une question quelle école
voulons du pour demain merci la parole
est maintenant à peu près collègue
françois fortassin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues à la rentrée prochaine cela a
été dit 4 en 1900 en france
supplémentaires seront accueillis à
l'école élémentaire et pourtant la ville
postes d'enseignants dans le primaire
vont être supprimés et 1200 en classes
de primaire fermée
cette décision est pour le moins
incompréhensible les rapports se suivent
et se ressemblent le constat est sans
appel
notre école souffre et une génération
d'enfants n'étant pas se sacrifier sur
l'autel des restrictions budgétaires
alors que des cadeaux fiscaux se
poursuivent et que la chasse aux niches
fiscales est bien timide
la cour des comptes le haut conseil du
casse de l'éducation en passant par les
travaux de nombreux parlementaires les
plus sérieuses instruction tire les unes
après les autres la sonnette d'alarmé
n'accorderont comme crédit à ces travaux
c'est se poser la question
toutefois il suffit de regarder autour
de nous pour mesurer l'ampleur des
dégâts
ou comment imaginer lutter contre
l'échec scolaire l'absentéisme la
violence et tous les autres maux dont
souffre notre école laïque républicain
républicaine en laissant des enseignants
de plus en plus seul de moins en moins
formés et face à des classes de plus en
plus surchargées l'égalité des chances
est abandonné au profit de la poursuite
des objectifs de la rgpp les principes
républicains et laïcs sont foulées aux
pieds
au grand désespoir de ceux qui comme moi
sont les produits de l'école réput de la
république pour tenter de calmer la
colère des familles des enseignants ou
encore celle des hellions nous allons ce
moratoire sur la fermeture des classes
mais monsieur le ministre cette mesure
pourrait s'apparenter à une manoeuvre
purement à visée purement électoralistes
on nous annonce le gère et la fermeture
des classes pour 2012
pourquoi pas cette amener les
territoires ruraux seront les plus
touchés et
votre politique semble nier à l'évidence
une un élément pourtant très important à
savoir que les enfants souvent peu
réceptive et parfois allergique à
l'autorité ne peut réussir que s'ils
sont dans des classes à faible effectif
dans les dix dernières années ce sont
1500 communes de notre pays qui ont vu
la dernière place et leur dernière notre
question mon cher collègue les quartiers
des villes sont pas mieux lotis
puisqu'ils s'étiole monsieur le ministre
que comptez vous faire pour que l'école
de la république puisse vivre en milieu
rural la parole était un monsieur lui
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur je
reviens sur vos propos concernant le
nombre moyen d'élèves par classe d'abord
monsieur le sénateur j'ai le regret de
vous dire qu'aucune étude ne démontre on
obtient de meilleurs résultats avec de
petits effectifs par rapport à des
effectifs nombreux
je vous encourage à toutes les études
qui sont parus sur le sujet deuxième
élément deuxième élément monsieur le
sénateur il se trouve qu'il y a moins
d'effectifs par classe que quand vos
amis étaient au gouvernement à la fin
des années 80 au début des années 90 et
d'ailleurs je vous donne les chiffres
précis il y aura à la rentrée prochaine
27 élèves par classe en moyenne dans les
lycées généraux ou technologiques ils
étaient 31 en 1989 90 il y aura à la
rentrée prochaine 19 élèves en moyenne
dans les lycées professionnels
ils étaient 23 à la fin des années 80
début des années 90 donc monsieur le
sénateur de grâce pas de faux procès
simplement monsieur le sénateur je crois
qu'aujourd'hui
l'enjeu pour faire réussir tous nos
élèves c'est d'être capable d'apporter
une personnalisation de l'enseignement
que nous n'avons pas su mettre en oeuvre
depuis 25 ans la conséquence de la
massification du service du système
éducatif qui est une bonne nouvelle
le fait d'avoir porté 100 % d'élèves au
collège d'avoir porté 65% de génération
qui présente le baccalauréat en ce
moment c'est une bonne nouvelle
sauf que nous n'avons pas mis en oeuvre
les moyens qui permettent d'assurer à
chacun une place à la sortie du système
éducatif et que nous avons
malheureusement aujourd'hui trop de
jeunes qui quittent le système éducatif
sans qualification sans diplôme 180
milles
d'après les statistiques que j'ai pu
obtenir en connectant nos réseaux
informatiques avec seul enseignement
agricole et ceux des centres d'apprentis
donc la réponse à tout cela pour lutter
contre l'échec scolaire pour lutter
contre l'échec scolaire en milieu rural
c'est la personnalisation tout au long
de la scolarité
c'est par exemple l'aide personnalisée
en primaire c'est la réforme du lycée
avec deux heures d'accompagnement
personnalisé qui permet aussi bien de
donner des méthodes de travail aux
jeunes qui ont du potentiel et qui
porteront vers l'excellence que de tenir
compte des élèves pour de grosses
difficultés auxquels nous devons
apporter de soutien scolaire en petits
groupes
c'est ça l'éducation nationale du futur
c'est un système différencié où nous
sommes capables là encore de faire
davantage d'avoir davantage de moyens
pour que les élèves qui ont des
difficultés plutôt qu'un système
égalitaire qui a montré toutes ses
limites ces dernières années par le
terme monsieur fortassin pour répondre
au ministre
oui monsieur le ministre j'ai du mal à
adhérer à votre théorie parce que d'un
côté vous nous dites que aucune étude ne
démontre que les effectifs importants
permettent de réussir - bienne et en
même temps on lui fera des petits
groupes
alors il ya quelque chose de là dessus
qui m'échappe
or vous savez très bien qu'en vingt ou
trente ans ce qui a changé c'est le
comportement des élèves
il était naturellement très réceptive
ils le sont un peu moins pour tout un
tas de raisons
et à l'évidence est bien quand on a été
pendant des élèves on s'aperçoit que
c'est plus difficile de mettre le chahut
khadir 15 élèves que kandia dans 35
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue madame colette mélot pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
vous avez la parole de dieu merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
président mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre en l'espace d'une
génération l'école a ouvert ses portes à
un nombre croissant d'élèves
elle a relevé le défi de la
massification aujourd'hui 66 % d'une
classe d'âge décroche son baccalauréat
contre -2 26% en 1981
néanmoins nous sommes tous conscients
que l'école doit évoluer elle doit
désormais relever le défi de la
démocratisation
on car ces mêmes résultats du
baccalauréat n'évolue plus depuis une
quinzaine d'années par ailleurs force
est de constater que l'école n'a pas
atteint tous ses objectifs de réalité le
démontre chaque année plus de 50 mille
jeunes quittent définitivement le lycée
sans le baccalauréat
un étudiant sur deux échoue en première
année universitaire aussi monsieur le
ministre vous avez décidé de mettre en
oeuvre une réforme du lycée elle
s'applique depuis la rentrée 2010 aux
classes de seconde générale et
technologique
cette réforme entre aujourd'hui dans sa
seconde phase
permettez moi de vous interroger plus
particulièrement sur la nouvelle classe
de première en effet la première
constitue une étape importante dans la
vie de l'élève
car elle est un premier pas vers une
spécialisation et un premier rendez vous
avec le baccalauréat avec des épreuves
anticipées
c'est pourquoi le répond à des défis
bien spécifiques
les élèves doivent pouvoir commencer à
s'orienter vers une spécialisation mais
en même temps il importe qu'il puisse
conserver la possibilité de changer
d'orientation en cours d'année par
conséquent ils doivent être mieux
accompagner dans leur parcours de
formation et d'orientation
monsieur le ministre ma question est la
suivante pouvez vous nous donner plus de
précisions sur la réforme du lycée pour
la rentrée 2011 je vous en remercie pour
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur
luc chatel ministre de l'éducation
nationale
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur colette mélot vous êtes très
attaché à une grande institution notre
système éducatif qui est le lycée c'est
pour cela que nous avons voulu le
réformer pour le moderniser surtout pour
lui permettre de relever les défis que
vous avez rappelé notamment faire en
sorte que davantage d'élèves accèdent
aux systèmes universitaires et
réussissent à l'université vous avez
rappelé qu'un étudiant sur deux qui
échoue en fin de première année
c'est un échec de l'ensemble de notre
système et nous devons y remédier alors
pour cela nous avons voulu mettre en
place un système entation beaucoup plus
progressif
en france nous avons trop souvent par le
passé estimé que le choix devait
s'opérer à 14 en sortant du collège
et parfois de manière systématique on
orientait les élèves quasiment pour la
vie on a le droit de ne pas savoir ce
qu'on va faire dans la vie à 14 ans on a
droit de se tromper on a droit de mûrir
ses choix et le système éducatif doit
être capable d'accompagner les élèves
dans leurs choix et de les guider
progressivement eh bien c'est ce système
d'orientation progressive réversible que
nous mettons en place progressivement
avec une rénovation de l'aide au conseil
de l'onisep avec un site interactif
extrêmement moderne qui répond aussi aux
problématiques de géolocalisation c'est
à dire fournir des conseils aux
étudiants aux élèves adaptés alors lieu
géographique localisation nous avons
également décidé de mettre en place un
système de tutorat parce qu'il ya des
élèves qui n'ont pas la chance d'avoir
des parents qui les aident dans ses
choix d'orientation parce qu'ils
connaissent mal d'écoles connaissent mal
le système éducatif donc nous devons
nous éduquer nationale a porté ce
soutien donc dorénavant l'orientation se
veut plus progressive avec l'idée de
passerelles entre les différentes
filières bac pro bac technologique bac
général et au sein du bac général entre
les différentes séries c'est pour sa
prochaine rentrée scolaire
il y aura un tronc commun en classe de
première qui comprendra environ 60% des
enseignements les autres heures étant
lié aux spécialisations
mais ces spécialisations ne sont pas
définitives et des réorientations seront
possibles à travers des stages
passerelles pour les élèves et puis
dernière nouveauté de la rentrée je
termine monsieur le premier temps c'est
la refonte du bac sti sciences et
techniques de l'industrie qui n'avait
pas été revu depuis 20 ans qui est un
bac technologique très important parce
que il débouche sur l'emploi sur
l'insertion professionnelle et c'est le
rôle de l'école que de préparer notre
jeunesse à s'insérer professionnellement
dans des filières porteuses bien un mode
homme le sénateur brièvement brièvement
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
pour cette réponse c'est vrai que la
réorientation a toujours posé un
problème très souvent elle était
impossible donc nous formons des voeux
pour que ce cette nouvelle procédure
puisse puisse voir le jour et que
beaucoup d'élèves puissent en bénéficier
merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
françoise cartron pour le groupe
socialiste avait la parole mon cher
collègue monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
récemment monsieur le ministre vous avez
déclaré la guerre au décrochage scolaire
une urgence évidente qui nécessite
d'ailleurs un véritable plan de bataille
malheureusement une fois de plus ce
n'était qu'une opération de
communication
car que constatons-nous l'enseignement
primaire terrain pertinent
d'intervention pour prévenir l'échec
scolaire est aujourd'hui sinistré avec
la fermeture de 1500 classes à la
rentrée prochaine
d'ailleurs combien de postes auront été
supprimés à la fin du mandat
présidentiel
cinquante mille soixante milles plus au
nom de la seule logique comptable dans
cet exercice de division multiple les
territoires ruraux payent le prix fort
oubliée la charte des services publics
en milieu rural signé en 2006 charte qui
prévoyait que toute fermeture de classes
devaient être anticipé 2 ans à l'avance
ignorer les efforts des maires pour
revêtir revitaliser leur commune
car comment impulser une dynamique
locale ce camp l'école abandonnée aux
seuls critères de rentabilité
les offres qui estime que puisque
harassant c'est dans ce contexte que
nous avons appris que des maires ne
voulant pas se résigner à cette mort
programmée embauches et rémunère des
enseignants nécessaires
se substituant ainsi à l'éducation
nationale défaillante
est ce là la solution monsieur le
ministre seront ils montrés du doigt
pour mauvaise gestion
qu'en pensez vous plus extraordinaire
la voix du nord fait écho de l'ouverture
par des écoles privées de classe payante
hors contrat pour les enfants de 2 3 ans
répondant ainsi je cite al attentes des
parents et aux besoins qui ne sont plus
prises en compte par l'éducation
nationale
c'est le directeur de l'enseignement
diocésain qui le dit voilà donc la
privatisation de la préscolarisation en
marche
on croit rêver votre question catholique
qui répondent aux besoins identifiés et
qui s'émeut du constat que les jeunes
enfants ne sont plus
comptabilisés dans l'éducation nationale
qu'en pensez vous monsieur le ministre
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur luc chatel ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse de
la mission le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur oui nous avons dû les déclarer
la guerre contre les grands chats
scolaire et ce n'est pas un exercice de
communication je vais essayer de vous
convaincre
premièrement personne je dis bien
personne ait compris mise de l'éducation
nationale le savez combien de jeunes
quitté le système éducatif chaque année
sans diplôme personnes nous le savons
dorénavant parce que nous avons pris la
décision de connecter les systèmes
d'information de l'éducation nationale
du land de l'enseignement agricole des
cfa des missions locales est dorénavant
je peux vous dire nous savons par
exemple que trois cent mille jeunes
étaient inscrits en juin dans nos
collèges et de lycées
au delà de 16 ans et n'étaient plus
présents au mois de mars 2011
sur ces 300 milles 180 milles était
considérée comme perdue de vue
c'est à dire des élèves dont on ne
savait absolument pas ce qu'ils étaient
devenus
dorénavant nous les connaissons et
deuxième élément de réponse
nous allons leur apporter une réponse
individualisée
c'est à dire que chaque préfet est en
train de mettre en place dans les
départements soit à l'échelle du
département soit bassin de vie par
bassin de vie une plateforme de lutte
contre le décrochage c'est à dire de
réunir tous les services de l'état
compétents éducation nationale
enseignement agricole cfa de manière à
ce qu'une réponse individualisée soin
apporté à ces décrocheurs donc g le
sénateur je réponds à votre question
vous m'interrogez prem's et vous avez
posé quatre questions en deux minutes
donc je réponds à la première question
qui concerne le décrochage scolaire qui
n'est pas une petite question valable
aux sénateurs et donc je vous réponds
que oui nous avons décidé de déclarer la
guerre contre le décrochage scolaire
deuxième élément de ma réponse nous
avons des résultats qui sont
encourageants vous verrez ils seront
publiés demain sur les évaluations de
ce1 qui montre que les acquis des élèves
en français et en mathématiques sont en
progrès et c'est la cohorte qui a
bénéficié de la réforme de
l'enseignement primaire de 2008
donc c'est une chose encourageant
dernier élément madame le
cela te rappelle que l'école est
obligatoire de 6 à 16 ans je rappelle
que 80 17% des enfants sont scolarisés à
partir de 3 ans et je rappelle que sur
les 2 3 ans je mène la politique tout le
maîtriser ses soeurs ont mené c'est à
dire que nous accueillons les enfants de
2 ans dans la limite des places
disponibles
merci monsieur le ministre mesdames car
front je suis désolé monsieur le
ministre de devoir vous dire que ce
n'est pas la réalité ce que vous
répondez puisque les enfants de 2 ans
qui sont accueillis ne sont pas
comptabilisés et c'est d'ailleurs le
directeur d'enseignement diocésain qui
le dit ce n'est pas quelques syndicats
d'enseignants donc comme ils ne sont pas
comptabilisés ne sont pas prises en
compte donc ils ne sont pas accueillis
dans la réalité et deuxième problème le
décrochage scolaire dont vous nous
parler j'ai voulu le relier à justement
ce manque de moyens qui est aujourd'hui
mis en place au sein de l'enseignement
primaire et sur lesquels je vous
demandait de revenir si l'on veut
vraiment s'attaquer à ce problème de
l'échec scolaire
merci la parole est maintenant à madame
brigitte gonthier maurin pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen sénateurs
du parti de gauche avaient la parole
merci monsieur monsieur le président
monsieur ministre chers collègues alors
que la rgpp le non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux partant à la
retraite a déjà provoqué la disparition
de cinquante six mille postes en quatre
ans la rentrée 2000 noms 11 ne signera
pas la fin de la destruction programmée
du service public de l'éducation
nationale seize mille nouveaux postes
seront supprimés dont 9 milles dans le
primaire alors que 60 mille élèves
supplémentaires sont attendus
l'annnonce de la fermeture de 1500
classes au primaire à d'ailleurs suscité
émoi et mobilisation le dessert scolaire
s'étant ainsi les 100 des territoires
enclavés isolé du service public de
l'éducation nationale comme des autres
aucun département n'était pas renié les
zones rurales très affectés se sont
fortement mobilisés en réponse à la
pression grandissante le président de la
république a opportunément annoncé un
moratoire sur les fermetures de classes
au primaire mais seulement pour de la
rentrée 2012 tout en confirmant la
poursuite du non remplacement d'un
départ sur deux à la retraite
2012 verra donc quatorze mille nouveaux
postes disparaître à la veille
d'élections
la ficelle est grosse ces annonces ne
met pas un terme au démantèlement du
service public de l'éducation nationale
c'est pourquoi il faut dès maintenant
stopper les suppressions de postes à
l'éducation nationale
ce préalable posé il faut tout urgent à
toutes aussi urgemment engagé la
religion la relance du processus de
démocratisation
car les réformes conduites par votre
majorité construisent une école
inégalitaire une école du tri social
avec d'un côté les élèves pour qui le
socle commun de connaissances et de
compétences constituerait un horizon
indépassable et ceux qui seraient
naturellement destiné à la poursuite
d'études au lycée dans l'enseignement
supérieur
ce n'est pas notre conception de l'école
concerne la question
nous voulons mettre l'école au service
de l'émancipation individuelle et
collective oui tous les élèves sont
capables de progresser et de réussir il
faut donc que l'école leur donne les
moyens d'y parvenir
quand allez vous donc monsieur le
ministre entendre cette exigence de
démocratisation répondent la parole de
monsieur lui ni de culture nationale
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame le
sénateur
nous avons clairement deux conceptions
de l'école qui s'affrontent depuis 30
ans votre seule réponse votre seule
réponse c'est la réponse des moyens
toujours plus de postes toujours plus de
moyens
est ce que madame le sénateur cette
réponse a obtenu des résultats
mais madame vous dénoncez vous même les
performances de notre système éducatif
au regard de ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays
et c'est vrai notre pays doit progresser
parce qu'il est 22e sur 65 dans les
classements internationaux pour la
compréhension de l'écrit ou le calcul
parce qu'on voit bien dans les enquêtes
internationales que nous dépensons plus
que la moyenne des pays développés dans
notre système éducatif
je vous encourage à regarder toutes les
études qui démontrent que la france
défense presque un point de plus de son
pib que la moyenne des pays de l'osce
étaient eux dans son système éducatif
alors que nous avons de moins bons
résultats que des pays qui investissent
moins que nous
donc madame le sénateur cette politique
elle a échoué la vraie réponse à hassi
fication la démocratisation que vous
évoquez et qui est peut-être le seul
point sur lequel pourront retrouver la
vraie réponse c'est une politique
d'adaptation de différenciation de
personnalisation auquel nous encourage
d'ailleurs la cour des comptes où toutes
les études qui ont été publiées sur ce
sujet par des organismes indépendants
alors vous lui fait un procès en
démocratisation madame le sénateur
je vais vous répondre qui est-ce qui a
créé les internats d'excellence qui sont
une réponse pour les enfants issus de
milieux défavorisés mais qui ont du
mérite et qui ont du potentiel pour
l'école c'est cette majorité 6000 places
aujourd'hui 1800 nouvelle place l'année
prochaine pour des enfants qui ont du
mérite qui ont du talent qui réussiront
grâce à l'écran mais en dehors de chez
eux qui a mis en place au sein des
établissements scolaires des stages de
remise à niveau pour les élèves qui ont
des difficultés
la semaine prochaine la première semaine
des vacances scolaires ou asnières
semaine des vacances scolaires à la fin
de l'été c'est cette majorité qui a mis
en place une aide personnalisée en
primaire de deux heures pour tous les
élèves qui ont des difficultés en
lecture
c'est cette majorité donc de grâce
madame le sénateur pas de leçons en
matière d'égalité des chances et de
démocratisation
pour vous répondre maintenant madame
compte y est mort à la réponse à la
question la démocratisation n'est pas
l'école du socle commun ni celle des
internats d'excellence monsieur le
ministre
pas de question de moyens vous dit
certes tellement mais tout de même je
veux donner quand même une illustration
concrète notamment en matière de
remédiation dans le collège jean macé de
clichy une classe de segpa va fermer car
tout simplement il ya un poste
d'enseignant qui vient de disparaître
conséquence on va mutualiser ses élèves
à double niveau 6e et 5e
une aberration alors qu'on le voit on le
sait ce sont des jeunes enfants d'une
part et qui sont confrontés à de réelles
difficultés qui auraient besoin d'un
angle d'un encadrement beaucoup plus au
quotidien est beaucoup plus conséquent
pire on propose à certains de ces les
élèves de se déplacer dans la ville d'à
côté ce sont des petits enfants donc on
va ajouter ou double
vaut le déplacement plus loin ce n'est
pas comme ça qu'on va construire une
école de l'égalité monsieur monsieur le
recteur unis mais on voit bien comment
vous arbitrage conduit salle inverse de
vos propos la parole est maintenant
notre collègue alain fouché pour le
groupe union pour un mouvement populaire
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la rentrée
prochaine relance la question des
rythmes scolaires trop souvent décriée
comme très lourd pour les enfants notre
système repose actuellement sur des
journées longues et fatigantes des
semaine de quatre jours inadaptée et une
année scolaire déséquilibrée par
comparaison avec nos voisins européens
nous avons l'année scolaire la plus
courte et une des journées les plus
longues
le pré-rapport sur les rythmes scolaires
dont une synthèse vous a été remise
monsieur le ministre a souligné la
volonté de changement quasi unanime pour
l'ensemble des personnes auditionnées
en ce sens vous avez monsieur ninis
décidé d'innover à la rentrée scolaire
de 2010 avec des expérimentations menées
dans certains établissements afin
d'instaurer une matinée de cours et une
seconde partie du jour consacré au sport
124 collèges et lycées de toute la
france avec l'adhésion des équipes
d'enseignants et des parents d'élèves
ont mis en place ce nouveau rythme
scolaire
chacun à sa manière le mois dernier vous
avez rendu compte de l'évaluation faite
de ces expérimentations
la direction générale de l'enseignement
scolaire a notamment souligné que
l'assiduité la motivation des élèves ont
fortement progressé
fort de ce résultat vous avez décidé sur
la base du volontariat des temps de
dispositifs dès septembre prochain 125
autres établissements d étude
expérimentale menée sur le système
canadien oil man font en effet état
d'effets positifs sur le comportement
social de les élèves de l'élève mais
elle démontre également que le gain sur
les résultats scolaires peut être
discutable
dès lors que l'on diminue le temps
d'apprentissage au profit du sport c'est
pourquoi monsieur le ministre souhaite
connaître l'objectif que vous poursuivez
à travers ce dispositif et quelles
dispositions vous comptez prendre dès la
rentrée 2011 pour inscrire cette
innovation dans une véritable refonte du
rythme scolaire vont répondre la parole
est à monsieur luc chatel ministre
éducation merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur alain fouché vous
avez raison finalement les petits
français passent plus de temps à l'école
que leurs camarades allemands
britanniques ou américains concentrer
sur un plus petit nombre de jours
un élève de primaire passent 144 jours à
l'école qu'entre 174 à 180 pour ses
camarades européens ou élèves de pays
développés membres de l' ocde
donc nous avons un travail de fond que
j'ai décidé d'engager avec la commission
nationale conférence nationale sur les
rythmes scolaires qui regroupe non
seulement les professionnels de
l'éducation nationale mais des élus
membres du parlement et des
collectivités territoriales mais aussi
des acteurs qui sont directement
concernés parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'organisation de l'école a des
conséquences sur tout le fonctionnement
de la société
la semaine prochaine le comité de
pilotage me rendra son rapport et je
ferai un certain nombre de propositions
après avoir entendu les différents
acteurs les différentes organisations
représentatives
vous avez rappelé monsieur foucher que
nous avons sans attendre engagé une
expérimentation de rythmes scolaires qui
permet d'avoir davantage d'activités
sportives pour les élèves
124 collèges et lycées sont concernés
cette aide et ils ont en moyenne ces
élèves cinq heures de sport de plus par
semaine
sport ou activités culturelles et
sportives nous avons fait une enquête
auprès des chefs d'établissement et nous
apercevons que 73% d'entre eux indiquent
que ces élèves qui expérimente cette
formule ont gagné en motivation 60% nous
indique que l'assiduité de ses élèves a
augmenté que le climat scolaire s'est
améliorée mais surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est que 42% des chefs
d'établissement nous disent que les
résultats scolaires
ces élèves se sont améliorées donc sans
attendre j'ai décidé d'étendre cette
expérimentation à la rentrée prochaine
et nous allons doubler le nombre
d'élèves
le nombre de classes concernées avec une
animation un partenariat avec un certain
nombre de fédérations sportives
j'ai signé récemment avec la fédération
française de rugby après d'autres
grandes fédérations
donc nous travaillons avec nos
professeurs d'éducation physique et
sportive et nous travaillons en
partenariat avec les fédérations et les
associations locales de manière à ce que
nos élèves bénéficient d'activités
sportives plus intense parce que
monsieur le sénateur push et le sport et
l'école partagent les mêmes valeurs
je couchais brièvement ministre agathe
des monts
merci messieurs minutes de votre réponse
cette expérimentation au vu des
résultats mérite effectivement d'être
développées et j'ai bien compris qu'elle
était développé je trouve ça très bien
merci mon cher collègue
la parole est maintenant à notre
collègue bérit débat pour le groupe
socialiste merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre nous avons appris
avec surprise voici quelques jours
l'annoncé par le président de la
république d'un moratoire sur les
fermetures de classes primaires en 2012
je me garderai bien entendu d'y voir un
quelconque rapport avec les échéances
électorales qui se dessine
je me garderais également de relever ici
les contradictions entre cette annonce
et la politique menée par votre
gouvernement dans ce domaine depuis plus
de quatre ans au nom de la rgpp
j'aurais tenté de m'en réjouir si je
n'avais pas appris le même jour que le
gouvernement avait confirmé 14 mille
suppressions de postes dans l'éducation
nationale pour 2012 en fin de compte je
suis donc surtout obligé de constater
que la rentrée prochaine sera marquée
encore une fois du sceau de la
désespérance l'actualité dramatique des
derniers jours en effet mis en lumière
les conséquences terribles des coupes
sombres qui sont réalisés depuis
maintenant cinq ans dans les effectifs
de l'éducation nationale
toutes catégories confondues cette
politique aveugle injuste et inefficace
nous conduit aujourd'hui dans une
impasse dont on voit mal comment on
pourrait en sortir
tout est à revoir un effet il ne sert à
rien de prétendre lutter contre l'échec
scolaire
si l'on ne paie pas ne permet pas aux
élèves les plus défavorisés de disposer
de conditions de suivi à la hauteur des
besoins et il est faux de plomb à
revaloriser la condition des enseignants
quand dans le même temps on envoie les
plus jeunes d'entre eux sur les postes
les plus difficiles comme on en voyait
naguère
les jeunes recrues au front d'ailleurs
les chiffres sont là qui montrent de
manière incontestable
la désaffection pour le métier
d'enseignant en 2007 ils étaient 33
milles à postuler au capes pour 6000
postes quatre ans plus tard ils ne sont
plus que douze mille cinq cents pour
4800 place cette désaffection est
préoccupante pour l'avenir de
l'éducation nationale pour les
enseignants eux mêmes et pour les uns
dans ce contexte monsieur le ministre
au lieu de nous dire encore une fois
comme vous l'avez fait jusqu'à présent
que tout va bien que tout ira bien pour
vos news nous indiquer quelles seront
les mesures les projets et les ambitions
qui feront de la rentrée 2012
une rentrée enfin réussi le ministre
pour répondre monsieur chatel merci
monsieur le président je pense que les
personnels de l'éducation nationale qui
gère la rentrée scolaire apprécieront la
fin de vos propos alors que la rentrée
scolaire est un exercice particulier
complexe 12 millions d'élèves puis 150
mille enseignants et que d'année en
année quels que soient les ministres
quels que soient les ministres on
constate que la rentrée scolaire se
passe dans de meilleures conditions
monsieur sénateur je ne vous
convaincrais pains manifestement mais si
on regardait objectivement les choses le
budget l'éducation nationale ces 60
milliards d'euros cette année
la france l'état va emprunter 180
milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire trois
fois le budget de l'éducation nationale
pouvait nous pouvons nous continuer
comme cela indéfiniment
pouvons-nous être suffisamment
responsables pour demande élèves qui
sont dans nos classes immédiatement un
chèque de 19 mille euros qui correspond
à la dette qu'ils auront à payer la
dette pour les dépenses que nous avons
effectués depuis 30 ans mais c'est la
réalité mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs donc face à cela quelle est la
réponse du gouvernement
la réponse du gouvernement elle est
d'être responsable et au moment où ils
rencontrent de grandes difficultés en
europe au niveau budgétaire
nous prenons nos responsabilités et nous
décidons de ne pas remplacer la moitié
des fonctionnaires qui partent en
retraite
alors monsieur le sénateur cette
politique j'ai l'impression que ça vous
dérange mais elle nous permet
de revaloriser nos enseignants oui parce
qu'il le mérite
parce qu'ils font un travail difficile
et parce que nous pensions que nous
devons recruter nos enseignants à un
niveau de formation initiale plus élevé
mieux payés mieux formés mieux
considérer c'est notre conception de la
valorisation du travail des enseignants
enfin je terminerai sur l'attractivité
aux métiers de l'enseignement
d'abord vous ne pouvez pas comparer un
recrutement au niveau bac +5 ou
mécaniquement le vivier est plus réduit
qu'un recrutement au niveau bac + 3 qui
était le recrutement en iufm auparavant
deuxièmement vous savez très bien que
cette année il ya eu deux concours à
quelques mois d'intervalle et que la
même cohorte d'étudiants a pu passer
deux fois le même concours donc là aussi
attendons sur la durée l'impact de la
mastérisation
mais notre objectif c'est bien de
recruter les meilleurs talents pour
exercer le métier de professeur monsieur
mairie de bas mon cher collègue
brièvement effectivement vous ne m'avez
pas convaincu mais ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas quelque chose d'étonnant sur le le
nombre je dirais de postes à pouvoir
il s'agissait du capes dont c'est pas
les post à nu fm n'ose rien à voir par
contre moi je constate que chaque jour
que l'application de la rgpp entraîne
quoi que vous disiez des problèmes
particulièrement important et
handicapant pour les pour les élèves et
pour les professeurs et je voudrais
simplement rebondir sur cette cet
événement qui s'est passé lundi dernier
papa hier où on s'est retrouvé avec 3000
copies de candidats au bac de philo qui
était en déshérence et c'est à dire que
il semblerait c'est assez surréaliste
que on a demandé qui veut des copies
qu'il veut des copies pour les corriger
alors que nous n'avions pas le nombre de
professeurs nécessaires pour assurer une
correction
voilà un exemple très concret de la
déshérence dans lequel se trouve notre
éducation nationale
la parole est maintenant un monsieur
yannick bodin pour le groupe socialiste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
après mon collègue mettez-moi d'enfoncer
le clou la rentrée scolaire 2011
s'annonce particulièrement difficile
1500 places on l'a dit son fait mais
créant un très vaste mouvement de
mécontentement
sinon de révolte alors sentant le danger
électoral de la poursuite d'une
politique de déconstruction de
l'éducation nationale le président de la
république a en effet annoncé qu'il n'y
aura pas de fermetures de classes dans
le primaire en 2012
après tout ça n'engage qu'un candidat à
la présidence de la ligue avant de se
réjouir
encore faudrait-il monsieur le ministre
se voir quelques assurances de votre
part alors je résume l'assurance par
exemple que vous n'allez pas une fois de
plus augmenté les effectifs par classe
réduire la scolarisation des enfants de
moins de 3 ans laissé se constituer des
établissements gay sociaux allez vous
cesser de supprimer les rased de
supprimer des options de supprimer des
formations de menacer l'avenir des
psychologues scolaires de faire
disparaître la médecine scolaire de
supprimer le corps des remplaçants
depuis plusieurs mois certaines
académies ont choisi de faire appel à
pôle emploi dans des situations
critiques
ainsi du rectorat de paris organisé une
campagne de recrutement de remplaçant
vie à pôle emploi afin de constituer son
vivier de remplaçants pour l'année
scolaire 2011 2012
mais l'éducation nationale n'était plus
un service public n'était plus capable
de recruter de former ses personnels
dois je revenir sur le problème que pose
cette méthode de recrutement
les volontaires sont sans doute de bonne
volonté
et on tue des diplômes et que
connaissent ti du métier d'enseignant
on apprend par ailleurs la désaffection
pour le métier d'enseignant chez les
étudiants la vocation d'enseigner summer
la disparition d'une formation certain
qu sion ce nom explique pour l'essentiel
qu'il y a de moins en moins les
candidats au concours alors on recrute
en faisant du n'importe quoi en 2011
16000 postes ont été supprimés ce qui
nous amène aux chiffres abyssal de 66000
poste depuis 2000 outre le fait que de
nombreux élèves ne cesse d'augmenter et
qu'il reste de plus en torrent longtemps
au sein de l'école les enquêtes
internationales ne glorifie pas notre
système éducatif je souhaiterais donc
savoir monsieur le ministre
s'il annonce de ne pas fermer de classes
dans le primaire à la rentrée 2012 va
enfin s'accompagnait d'un gel de coupes
budgétaires pour l'éducation nationale
pour l'année qui vient
ou si cette annonce est tout simplement
de la poudre aux yeux en direction des
français c'est-à-dire des électeurs qui
de toute façon ne vous inquiétez pas ne
seront pas dupes où vous répondre la
parole et à luc chatel ministre question
nationale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs j'ai parfois du mal à vous
suivre puisque pendant des mois vous
nous avait alerté sur la situation en
milieu rural le président de la
république considère que pour la rentrée
2012 il faut évoluer et non pas mettre
en place un moratoire mais faire en
sorte qu'il n'y aura pas plus de
fermetures que d'ouvertures c'est à dire
le même nombre de classes à la rentrée
2012 que la rentrée 2011 et vous vous
indignez donc on a du mal à vous suivre
monsieur le sénateur je suis désolé de
vous le dire monsieur le sénateur je
vous veux répondre sur une chose moi ce
qui m'intéresse ce sont les résultats de
nos élèves
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de voir si
notre système éducatif est capable
d'être plus performants aujourd'hui
compte tenu des exigences et des
attentes des parents qu'il ne l'était
avant bien monsieur le sénateur je vais
vous dire nous avons mis en place un
système que vous avez contestée est un
système d'évaluation d'évaluation de nos
élèves
en cm2 et en ce1 merci vous regarder
objectivement les choses sortons des
querelles politiciennes
quelques instant monsieur le sénateur je
sais que nous sommes filmés
je sais qu'à une campagne pré électorale
mais moi j'aimerais qu'à un moment on
parle de l'école de manière dépassionnée
si on regardait les résultats
objectivement monsieur gaudin et bien
les résultats objectif qu'est ce qu'ils
vous disent ils vous disent que cette
année les élèves de ce1 sont 50% à avoir
obtenu des acquis très solides
c'est six points de plus que l'année
dernière six points de plus que l'année
dernière
ça veut dire que la première cohorte qui
a bénéficié de la réforme de 2008 du
primaire les programmes revus sur les
fondamentaux le soutien scolaire
personnalisé avec de l'aide à la lecture
et bien cette première cohorte elle a
effectué ces évaluations et al obtient
des résultats qui sont bien meilleurs
que l'année dernière c'est ça qui
m'intéresse mais sur le seul sénateur
ce qui m'intéresse c'est que notre
système éducatif soit capable de se
moderniser de s'adapter de différencier
ses moyens et au total d'obtenir de
meilleurs résultats et non pas de rester
dans des querelles veine du passé
monsieur gaudin brièvement parce que
vous avez fait une pré consommation du
temps oui bah je serai très bref je dois
dire que je ne sais pas comment vous
allez expliquer aux français qu'on peut
à la fois dire on ne fermera pas de
classe l'année prochaine dans le
primaire et en même temps dire on va
supprimer 14 mille postes ça c'est
absolument incompréhensible
deuxièmement vous avez vu ou par les
dévaluations me prononcer une évaluation
qui concerne l'ensemble des élèves
vous avez quand même constater que d'une
enquête pisa à l'autre enquête
internationale pisa ça se dégrade
puisqu'on est passé en ce qui concerne
les élèves en difficulté à l'âge de 15
ans de 15% à 20%
or ça fait dix ans que vous gouvernez
service bientôt cinq ans que le
président de la république est en train
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait de moins
en moins d'adultes à l'éducation
nationale et il faut pas s'étonner donc
de voir quelle est la situation
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui et en
ce qui concerne la prochaine rentrée si
les parents d'élèves et six tonneaux
conclure c'est a de bonnes raisons
c'est une conclusion suffisante pour des
rendez vous l'année prochaine
merci je voudrais vous remercier
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
d'avoir participé à cette séance de
questions cribles thématiques très
intéressante je vais maintenant
suspendre la séance elles sont rares
prises à 18 heures pour la désignation
des 19 membres de la mission commune
d'information sur la suppression de la
taxe professionnelle et son remplacement
par la contribution économique
territoriale
puis la deuxième lecture la proposition
de loi tendant à améliorer le
fonctionnement des maisons
départementales des personnes
handicapées que j'ai évoqués au cours de
l'après midi
la séance est suspendue
c'est la fin de cette séance de
questions cribles consacré la rentrée
scolaire pour la revoir notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
à suivre à 18h15 à l'émission
déshabillons-les présenté est préparée
par hélène risser avec comme thématique
aujourd'hui martine aubry la première
secrétaire du parti socialiste qui a
annoncé sa candidature aux primaires
très belle soirée à tous